the president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Putin and the chairman of
People's Republic of China are signing
the joint statement of the Russian
Federation in China on deepening the
overall relations between the two
countries and the joint statement of the
president of the Russian Federation and
the chairman of the uh
People's Republic of China
on
Mutual cooperation up to 2030.
uh as part of the visit of the chairman
of People's Republic of China a number
of
intergovernmental and Inter national
agreements have been signed between
Russia and China
the ceremony is over and we are starting
the Press statement of the Russian
President Vladimir Putin and the
chairman of
People's Republic of China Xi Jinping
dear
chairman Xi Jinping
dear ladies and gentlemen
dear friends
we are sincerely glad
to have this opportunity to welcome our
friend chairman of People's Republic of
China Xi Jinping all our negotiations
yesterday and today
one to one and in
um in extended circles have been very
successful and they were conducted in
very friendly
manner we've signed two program
statements and they reflect fully
reflect the nature of Russia China
relations which are the highest point
of taking the whole history of our two
countries and they they Encompass our
comprehensive relationships
Russia and China are tied together
through
through our good neighborly relations
we are supporting active
dialogue and we are in constant contact
with the chairman of China
we are meeting on at international
events and we regularly speak
through video conferencing and
in in phone conversations
and this allows us to find even in most
complex situations Solutions
to the problems and we are able to
discuss all current issues uh
international
issues and of course our priority is
trade and economy
and that's quite natural take into
account that China is the leading trade
partner of our country
our states
are keeping a high dynamics of
international trade which grew by 30
percent last year
and we have established a new record of
80 billion dollars
in this current year we are going to
exceed 200 billion trade volume and we
are focusing on key areas of development
of 2023 and we have
established an objective to increase our
volume of cooperation in Aid strategic
areas
industrial Financial Logistics and
transportation
the government of Russia and China
business Circles of the two countries
have to immediately start working on
practical implementation of measures
and that will be mutually
beneficial
trade and investment cooperation
is an important area and as part of it
there will be increased Mutual
settlements in our national currencies
we have reached 65 percent of trade
volume with settlements in our local
currencies and this will allow us to
secure international trade from
influences of third countries
and reduce our exposure to currency
Market
we have discussed our cooperation in the
field of energy and we have very
positive Dynamics
China is the leader in importing the
Russian oil and we are going to increase
the supply of oil for the needs of
Chinese economy as for the prospects of
a Russian Chinese Corporation in the gas
area
Russia has increased the volume of
supply of gas by 1.5 times since 2010
and gasprom has been very accommodating
to the requests of our Chinese
colleagues and even exceeded the volumes
contract volumes of supply and that
demonstrates gas problem as a as a
reliable partner in the future
um
our agreement in January was signed to
to
build another
pipeline gas pipeline that will be
connecting Russia and China and we
talked with our partners we have
achieved all necessary agreements and
this will ensure 50 billion cubic meters
of gas of stable supply of gas to China
we also discussed the supply of
liquidified natural gas to China and in
the nearest Future these supplies will
increase
we talked about peaceful nuclear
industry
Russia is building a nuclear power plant
in China and we are working on block 7
and 8 in one of the power stations and
also building new blocks for the second
power stations the corporation
will be
will be insured through the long-term
program that was signed by the Chinese
nuclear Authority
we are also working on
bilateral industrial cooperation
automatically
car manufacturers from China are
increasing their presence in China in
Russia and we are increasing our
cooperation in biotechnology
Pharmaceuticals and other areas
strategic direction of Chinese Russian
cooperation includes agriculture we are
growing significantly in terms of volume
of supplies of food products and we are
also looking at opportunities to export
significant volumes of grain and meat to
China
we are developing International logistic
corridors
and we want to
use the potential of Trans-Siberian
Railway to the maximum and also we want
to use the potential of the Northern sea
route and trans Asian
highways motorways
and we would like to increase the
efficiency of transportation and cargo
flows
we are increasing the capacity of our
border crossings and we are increasing
the infrastructure on our borders
last year
to border crossings Railway Crossing and
Motorway Crossing were commissioned
between Russia and China
and we are also increasing our
humanitarian cooperation after the
coveted restrictions have been lifted
we're coming back to our previous
intense levels of cultural and tourist
exchanges
and this will deepen our connection and
friendship Mutual understanding and uh
friendship between our two countries I
would like to remind you that
2022-2023 were announced to be the years
of cooperation in uh
physical education and sports
we are
we are involving uh
but we are involving youth in in this
relationship and we are expecting
the
athletes from China next year in Kazan
who will be participating in the uh
competitions in that area
these competitions will include also
digital elements
this is a great initiative that can be
promoted together with our Chinese
friends and we've proposed to them to to
become the hosts of second such games in
their own country
we discussed a number of international
and Regional projects program problems
we
talked about the fact that our
viewpoints on certain areas uh
um are aligned we discuss certain
problematic areas
and we see that
um
increased application of illegitimate
restrictions that are being applied
and uh illegitimate means of
competition that is used by certain
countries
and we would like to promote free access
to
to education and Technologies and in
this regard China and Russia
are against
other countries
restricting restricting activities of
um of their Partners which gives them uh
advantage
we believe that
many points of the Chinese peace plan
correlates to to the point of view of
the Russian Federation and many of these
points can be adopted in the west and in
Kiev we believe that
however we we do not see the Readiness
from their side for this moreover just
now I was told that while
we were discussing with the chairman the
opportunities for implementing the
Chinese peace plan
the
chairman spent a lot of
time
uh and and put a lot of attention on
this peace initiatives during our
conversations it became clear today it
became known that
United Kingdom
um
using the deputy Minister of Defense
announced
of the announced their supply not just
of the tanks but also depleted uranium
ammunition
they are trying to fight the this
conflict not just using the not just in
theory using the last Ukrainian but in
actual practice
and we will have to react
to this Collective West is is now
starting to use the weapons with uh
nuclear elements
would like to emphasize that uh China
and Russia are conducting independent
Regional policy we are in favor of uh
multipolar development and this has to
have at its core United Nations and we
believe that
it is important to continue to support
the cooperation within Shanghai
cooperation organization and we have to
work within the group of 20 and using
other platform International platforms
and of course we have to continue our
efforts on
integration processes in Nieves
and
we would like to form in the future
great Eurasian partnership I would like
to thank XI jinpin and all our Chinese
friends for our productive cooperation
and I'm confident that the agreements
that have been achieved during this
visit will be the basis for future
growth and development of our countries
and of our people thank you for your
attention
thank you
about your family
foreign
crazy um
purpose
truly every time
George and family
thank you
foreign
champions
event
ually
foreign
[Applause]